manchmal ist sie unbequem und schwer
auszuhalten doch sie ist die basis
unserer liberalen demokratie und
meinungsfreiheit des andersdenkenden
nur der meinungspluralismus garantiert
unsere freiheit
einer aktuellen studie zufolge jedoch
ist die meinungsfreiheit in deutschland
in gefahr
so zumindest sieht es eine mehrheit der
befragten und damit begrüße ich sie sehr
hat sich zu einer neuen ausgabe von
unter den linden
[Musik]
und hier am tisch begrüße ich sehr
herzlich haben professor harald welzer
soziologe und sozialpsychologe herzlich
willkommen und ich begrüße sehr herzlich
professor norbert bolz
medienwissenschaftler und philosoph
herzlich willkommen an sie beide er
professor welter in der vergangenen
woche hat eine umfrage des
allensbach-instituts furore gemacht 45
prozent der befragten haben nur
angegeben dass sie ihrem einheit ihre
meinungsfreiheit tatsächlich frei äußern
können ihre meinung frei äußern können
wenn man sie gefragt hätte was hätten
sie geantwortet ja ich hätte schon
gesagt dass man in diesem land seine
meinung frei äußern darf
ich sehe auch keinen grund gegenteiliger
auffassung zu sein
also das ist ja schlicht und ergreifend
einfach so sie hätten auch gar nicht
nachgedacht und gezuckt sondern direkt
gesagt natürlich kann ehrlich ich hätte
wirklich gesagt ohne jedes zucken
natürlich selbstverständlich können wir
in diesem land sagen was wir wollen was
hätten sie denn der antworte ich hätte
gesagt dass wir das können wenn wir
bereits in einem ziemlich hohen preis zu
bezahlen
denn sehr viele meinungen die man
natürlich rein offiziell im formalen
äußern darf ohne ins gefängnis zu kommen
oder geldstrafen zu bekommen werden sehr
scharf sanktioniert
und das kann einem den job kosten das
kann einem die karriere kosten
und dafür gibt es mittlerweile schon
eine fülle auch sehr prominenter
beispiele
also es ist eine schein freiheit wenn
sie so wollen eine schein freiheit der
meinungsäußerung und sehr sehr viele
menschen und wie die umfrage zeigt ist
das offensichtlich überall schon
angekommen
sehr sehr viele menschen haben eben
dieses bestimmte empfinden es sei klüger
zu bestimmten positionen gar nichts zu
äußern oder das was den mainstream
eigentlich ausmachen ja sind sie haben
es gesagt ist eine mehrheit 55 prozent
sind skeptisch dass man seine meinung
hier tatsächlich frei äußern kann
das ist ja mehr als der kumulierte
stimmenanteil von protestparteien würde
ich mal sagen
das heißt dass auch alle couleur von
protest dabei im zweifel dabei ist
was würden sie sagen gibt es da ein
eigenes werk merkmal zwischen denen die
das skeptisch sind das einzige
gemeinsame merkmal der skeptiker oder
derjenigen die die meinungsfreiheit eben
bedroht sehen ist für meine begriffe
eine realistische wahrnehmung unserer
wirklichkeit
man sieht das einfach hört es bekommt es
mit wie es leuten ergeht die einmal eine
meinung äußern die gegen den strich der
offiziellen wenn sie so wollen
mainstream meinung geht und viele haben
dafür ich habe es schon angedeutet
bezahlen müssen sehr sehr viel bezahlen
müssen es ist nämlich eines der
argumente dass von den vertretern die
ich sagen es gibt gar kein problem weder
mit politische correctness noch mit
seilen sing oder die plattform es gibt
kein problem mit der meinungsäußerung
insgesamt dass sie sagen guckt doch hin
schaut euch irgendeinen extremen fall an
wie sarrazin
der kann doch sagen was er will er
schreibt bücher die massen auflagen
haben es nummer eins der
spiegel-bestsellerliste regelmäßig also
reine meinungsfreiheit nur dann vergisst
man gerne die anschlussfrage was ist der
preis dafür
und der preis ist ost rassismus
isolation wenn sie so wollen auf die
seite der unmenschen gestellt zu werden
und für kleinere geister die sich nicht
mit tantiemen dann über wasser halten
können
für kleinere geister bedeutet das dann
meistens ende der karriere
stellen sie sich vor man würde bestimmte
dinge am anfang einer
universitätskarriere äußeren dinge die
ich vielleicht an meinem am ende meiner
universitätskarriere habe äußern können
weil ich wusste mir kann nichts mehr
viel passieren wäre ich 35 gewesen hätte
ich das niemals gesagt aus klugheit
ausfällt vernünftig bin muss meine
familie ernähren ich muss an meinen
weiterkommen denken mein gedanke war
dann einfach ok in ein zwei jahren wird
das so funktioniert jetzt kann ihnen
niemand mehr was tun
ich spreche offen aus aber das sind nur
ganz ganz wenige leute die in dieser
schönen position sind in der ich bin
oder in der ich auch von bayern war
nichts zu sagen
dirk ahnt niemand mehr an den wagen
fahren hier kann niemand mehr deine
karriere wegnehmen viele jüngere und
gerade großartige intelligente menschen
junge assistentin junge professoren
denken 34 mal drüber nach was sie sagen
zu bestimmten themen das ist ein
vernichtendes urteil was unsere
meinungsfreiheit angeht sehen sie das
auch nähe ich denke gerade die ganze
zeit angestrengt darüber nach in welcher
welt sie sich aufhalten
also das ist mir ein bisschen rätselhaft
und das beispiel sarrazin sie haben es
ja selber gesagt eigentlich ein
entlegenes beispiel war ja nicht so viel
diskutiert wurde
zumindest sein erstes buch wie eben
dieses buch wie ich fand völlig über
diskutiert angesichts der qualität aber
was nehmen sie da war ich verstehe das
überhaupt nicht verstehe das auch nicht
mit dem akademischen nachwuchs
wer wer fährt den sanktionen wegen was
in diesem land was ist denn das für ein
phantasma einfach das beispiel dass es
überhaupt gibt trifft die ärmsten der
armen katholischen welt diesen kleinen
biotop in dem wir beide leben existieren
studenten an vielen universitäten die
nicht ändern in ihren arbeiten bekommen
punktabzug
ich glaube dass eklatanter geht es
überhaupt nicht dass auch sein das soll
wirklich an der grenze zur zensur man
kann natürlich sagen jeder uni habt ihr
das recht ohne ende das doch unglaublich
waren ja mal gemeinde knapp gesagt
einige universitäten und das ist
unbezweifelbar
sie haben gesagt sie verlieren sozusagen
in die qualität der note wenn sie nicht
denn da ist es nicht so dann müssen sie
es benennen wo das der fall ist mir
persönlich ist das nicht bekannt hat an
den universitäten wo ich tätig bin ist
es auch nicht der fall also aber auch
das ist ja jetzt so trivial ich würde
das ja gar nicht in abrede stellen dass
das vielleicht irgendwo der fall ist
aber sie stellen das so da auch in ihrem
eingangs statement dass es sozusagen
eine repression gibt also wie in
weißrussland anscheinend oder so was ich
verstehe nicht welche gesellschaft sie
hier thematisieren ich weiß auch nicht
von welcher position sollte über die
hälfte der bevölkerung lebt an der
wirklichkeit vorbei
das kann viele gründer ich weiß das
liegt wahrscheinlich daran dass leute
wie ich propagandistisch so wirken dass
über die hälfte der bevölkerung glaubt
wir würden ich meine meinung haben sie
denn so eine fürchterliche angst ich
habe keine angst niki dass er persönlich
ausgezeichnet die gründer hab ich schon
genannten er kann niemand mehr was tun
ich setz mich aber in die lage
beispielsweise auch meine eigenen kinder
die alle vier studieren beziehungsweise
studium schon abgeschlossen haben und
die mir sehr regelmäßig und ohne große
aufregung auch berichtet haben wie das
so an universitäten mittlerweile abläuft
nun kenne ich zugegebenermaßen nur die
berliner universitäten durch eigene
erfahrung und durch die meiner kinder
aber das scheint mir doch sehr
repräsentativ zu sein aber jetzt können
wir doch mal
sozusagen zur sache geben ich finde das
sehr interessant ich will das ja gar
nicht pauschal in abrede stellen das ist
sozusagen den versuch gibt sprach
diktatur sprachregelungen und so weiter
massiv durchzusetzen und häufig
sozusagen neben der wissenschaftlichen
sache da können wir sofort einen konsens
darüber herrscht
die frage ist nur wo und warum ist das
möglich und ich würde bei den fällen die
mir bekannt sind zum beispiel eine große
schwäche ein großes versagen der
entsprechenden universitätsleitungen
sehen sie sich dann auf seiten der
studierenden schlägt sondern ich auf
seiten der angegriffenen kolleginnen und
so sehr
und dann muss man gucken okay was
passiert da und wir reden ja jetzt über
das akademische milieu die 55 prozent
aus der meinungsumfrage sind ja
wahrscheinlich nicht 55 prozent aus dem
akademischen milieu und da ist ja noch
mal eine frage warum äußern die sich so
ja also habe man leicht beantworten
nehmen sie die großen themen unserer
zeit klima migration schulden und dann
haben wir noch gleich zwei professoren
in diesen großen themen haben sie eine
fülle von dabei gleich noch intensiv zur
welt lassen lass uns noch mal die
ursachenforschung auch in angriff nehmen
wenn 55 prozent tatsächlich sagen dass
sie ihre meinungsfreiheit gefährdet
sehen muss man dann konstatieren dass
eine minderheit ein meinungs-
dogmatismus durchsetzt nein also nur
weil menschen das so sehen es ist ja
noch kein empirischer sachverhalt dass
es so ist wir haben also denken sie an
corona querdenker denken sie an
verschwörungstheorien
der umstand dass menschen so etwas
wahrnehmen ist noch nicht der beleg
dafür dass etwas der fall ist okay also
kanonen und sowas obwohl es viele leute
glauben würden wir wahrscheinlich zu
dritt hier sagen können wahrscheinlich
nicht und das wäre eine interessante
frage ich war über diese umfrage auch
überrascht wo kommt das jetzt her
naja und dann müssen wir mal gucken
welche form von kommunikation welche
form von mythenbildung ist bereich der
letzten anderthalb jahre gegeben hat
durch die
debatte um corona was es im zusammenhang
sozusagen dieser ganzen direkt medien
gibt ich fühle mich zum beispiel
überhaupt nicht mainstream mäßig
kontrolliert aus dem einfachen grund
weil ich nicht in sozialen netzwerken
bin und mich null interessiert wer da
irgendwie im hintergrund irgendwelche
seine meinung über mich artikulieren es
mir völlig unter und dann entstehen ja
phantasmen von von kommunikation und so
also deswegen und würden sie sagen dass
ich dann auch keine eliten dominanz in
irgendeiner form angekündigt oder
andeutet geliebten dominanz auch das ist
ja jetzt eine schwierige kategorie ich
habe das heißt eliten dominanz also
leuten die sagen ich habe jetzt die
deutungshoheit und ich bestimme was
gesagt wird
ich würde sagen der gender diskurs ist
ein sehr akademischen diskurs und sehr
elitäre discos und erstelle will ich das
sagen ich würde in bezug auf die klima
thematik überhaupt nicht sagen ich würde
es in bezug auf den migrations thematik
auch nicht sagen aber es gibt natürlich
also je mehr wir ins symbolische gehen
desto mehr wird das glaube ich eliten
diskurs weil vieles ist ja auch nicht
einfach zu verstehen weil es da so
artikuliert wäre es kann sehr schönen
artikel in der taz die ja nun wirklich
nicht in gefahr ist rechtslastig oder
konservativ zu sein
und in der tat stand dann sogar als
überschrift die leute werden schon noch
nachgeben also diejenigen die immer noch
widerstand leisten gegen das zu ändern
der sprache also man hat dann auch eben
bestimmte untersuchungen gemacht immer
wieder das gleiche die mehrheit der
bevölkerung oder zwei drittel leben und
das abhalten das für unsinn und die taz
schreibt dann sehr schön und die taz ist
immer sehr offen und klar das finde ich
bewundernswert
wir machen das einfach weiter das
sickert immer weiter durch irgendwann
wird niemand mehr sich werden und das
ist die reine politisch mediale elite
die da spricht und deshalb halte ich das
für eines der zentralen probleme unserer
zeit wir leben in einer zeit der eliten
herrschaft und leider gottes in die
theoretiker die das prognostiziert haben
nicht gerade wie sympathischsten
gestalten die einfach studie hat ja
nicht nur das gender thema als als thema
ausgemacht sondern
auch die themen patriotismus und
glaubensfragen lassen sich diese themen
alle einem spektrum zuordnen
ich glaube sie haben tatsächlich einen
gemeinsamen nenner nämlich sie sind alle
wie soll man sagen traditionalistisch
konvertiert also es gibt eine sagen wir
mal ganz einfach alle leute die im
grunde auffassungen haben die vor 20
jahren mehr oder minder jeder geteilt
hat oder fast alle geteilt haben alle
großen politischen parteien alle formen
von öffentlichkeit es gab alle diese
leute die dieselben auffassungen heute
noch vertreten gelten als wenn sie glück
haben konservativ meistens als rechts-
oder gar als ewiggestrig und reaktionär
und das ist glaube ich das problem dass
sehr sehr viele leute haben nicht nur
die älteren dass sie nämlich merken dass
man mit meinungen die beispielsweise
berühmte politiker der jüngeren
vergangenheit der cdu genauso wie der
spd ganz selbstverständlich
ausgesprochen haben sogar leute der
grünen dass die heute als rechtsextrem
gelten und daraus zieht man natürlich
die konsequenz halt lieber den mund zum
islam geht wenn es um massenmigration
geht wenn es um schulden union geht es
gibt leute die große politiker
politikerinnen vor allen dingen der
letzten jahre die die schuldenunion
hundertprozentig abgelehnt haben die
noch klar gesagt haben nur über meine
leiche kommt nicht in frage
23 jahre später ist das die einzige
wahrheit das einzige was man überhaupt
wer das nicht tut ist in europa feind
genau dasselbe mit der migration frau
merkel sagt multikulti ist gescheitert
es geht überhaupt nicht weiter schily
grüne oder dann spd sagt das boot ist
voll vor 15 jahren heute unter
extremsten bedingungen gilt genau das
entgegengesetzte mehr herein als sie
zwei hervorragend welcher welt leben das
ist die wirklichkeit
doch in kann ich allerdings und zwar
ziemlich gut nämlich wenn man die
flüchtlingszahlen anguckt die ja nun
erheblich gesunken sind durch eine
politik über die bei uns an anderer
stelle unterhalten können
aber wo kommt jetzt dieses phantasma
dass sie glauben man könne also man wäre
rechtsextrem als rechtsextrem denunziert
wenn man eine äußerung zur
flüchtlingspolitik oder sonst macht wer
greift sie denn sein neuester und macht
sondern wenn man die offizielle politik
angreift ist es vielleicht eine frage
der debattenkultur wenn wir sagen nur 45
prozent der menschen sagen ich kann hier
frei meine meinung äußern geht es dann
letztendlich mehr um die form und nicht
so wie inhalte der debatte
ich kenne ich hab jetzt keine analyse
sozusagen dieser zahlen
die kann ich ihnen jetzt nicht vorlegen
also wie die tiere was vermuten sie ist
oder könnten sie es verboten
naja ich vermute es gibt in umfragen
sehr viele dinge dass wir das so zu
sagen bin gespannt was sie dazu sagen
wenn man das qualitativ verfolgen würde
also jetzt die leute die ihr kreuz
hinter gemacht haben fragen würde was
meinen sie denn genau was verbirgt sich
denn hinter dieser äußerung dann würden
die irgendwas erklären und dann könnten
wir gucken wo durch sind diese 55
prozent hinterlegt er und was das für
soziale gruppen die das sagen und so
weiter und so weiter
und dann könnten wir qualifiziert
darüber reden aber ich finde trotzdem
ich muss nochmal darauf beharren auch
weil sie unsere welten sicher sehr stark
unterscheiden sind ja im leben vor ort
wissen wir ja aber wir haben ja genau
hier den effekt die wir die welt in der
herr bolz sich aufhält das
offensichtlich eine andere als in der
ich mich aufhalte prozent ja und
wahrnehmung ist eben etwas was realität
sehr stark prägt und die wirklichkeit
vorstellung so und dann würde ich anders
gucken und sagen wo gibt es denn
tatsächlich die repression wo gibt s
denn diese fälle die sie beschreiben
ich würde sagen dass es in einem
bestimmten elitären teil einer keine
ahnung symbol linken oder sowas den
versuch gibt da an bestimmten
fachbereichen dominanz zu erwirken
das wäre ungefähr mein empirischer
bereich und die andere frage
bei dem sender noch mal auch da müsste
man ja sagen was ist denn möglicherweise
einfachen modernisierungsprozess also
ich sage schon seit vielen jahren
studierende und nicht studenten und ich
sage es an vielen stellen wo es mir
sinnvoll
reisen sie warum es kein
modernisierungsprozess ist weil er top
down ist wie alles was diese das ist
politisch mediale elite von oben wird
das bestimmt es gibt einige wenige und
in der tat sie haben recht die letzte
quelle ist sogar unser lustiger campus
also der campus die universität ist wenn
sie so wollen die brutstätte für diese
ideologie und die werden jetzt von oben
nach unten durchgedrückt und zwar
einfach in durch ständiges wiederholen
und niemals nachlassen
und weil man einen privilegierten zugang
zu den medien hat kann man das auch
erfolgreich durchsetzen sollte hier dann
von einem fliegenden gesinnungs karmann
sprechen nach ich meine man könnte mal
über dieses disziplinen sprechen wenn
sowas in den kulturwissenschaften der
große hype ist ist es in der mathematik
oder physik in der biologie und in der
ökonomie noch lange nicht angekommen
also automatik haben sie nicht nur
mathematik aber wer weiß wer weiß das
sind auch spezial des chores sender ein
solcher ist politisch bis zum äußersten
das ist nicht nur sache der
universitäten verändern wenn der
mainstreaming sender in der sprache wird
ja gerade von den medien auch nicht nur
praktiziert sondern vorangetrieben aber
lassen wir haben konkretes bei ich bin
mal bringen weil sie sagen wer ist das
denn der unterdrückt wird oder wer muss
denn leiden oder etwas zahlen
ein wunderbares aktuelles beispiel
leider kann ich jetzt den namen nicht
nennen aber jeder weiß um was es geht
ich glaube in hamburger professor der
die these aufgestellt hat eine these die
ihn und weiß wird niemanden besonders
überrascht hat nämlich dass es möglich
wäre dass der coup 19 erreger aus einem
chinesischen labor stammt was war die
reaktion ich glaube so lange können wir
uns alle gut erinnern
verschwörungstheoretiker das ist eine
verschwörungstheorie
und heute ich habe nicht bemerkt dass
irgendjemand sich bei diesen professor
entschuldigt hätte heute ist dass ich
will nicht sagen die offizielle linie
aber doch eine der auch offiziell von
der politik sehr wahrscheinlich
angesehenen erklärungen und das halte
ich für ein wunderbares beispiel sind
sagen irgendetwas nur eine
wissenschaftliche hypothese oder eine
these die es in den raum stellen und man
sagt ihnen nicht dass es falsch oder mal
widerlegt sie nicht sondern sagt sie
sind ein unmenschliches sind nicht ganz
klar bei ihr aber das sind und nehmen
sie nur den
einen punkt noch die konjunktur aller
möglichen begriffe mit phobie
islamophobie homophobie und ähnliches
mehr das heißt auf deutsch du bist gegen
eine bestimmte politik die zur zeit
praktiziert wird
du bist aber eben nicht nur ein gegner
dieser politik sondern du bist
geisteskrank na ja sagen dass das ist
uns heute vielleicht auch ein stück weit
schwerer fällt die meinung der anderen
auszuhalten als das vielleicht noch
früher der fall war wo man früher jetzt
sehr unbestimmt
also ich glaube schon dass wir sozusagen
in der politischen kultur der
diskussionskultur sehr binär sind also
das ist das ist eine starke tendenz
danach gibt etwas als für richtig oder
falsch zu erklären
wobei mein weltbild und wie ich die
dinge sehe ist immer sehr differenziert
und schattiert würde ich sagen in
unterschiedlichen farbtönen insofern das
geht mir auf die nerven
da würden wir sogar vielleicht davor
sein aber ich würde trotzdem nochmal auf
die rolle dieser direkt medien
zurückkommen weil es hier einfach so ist
das was herr bolz jetzt sozusagen als
großen gesellschaftlich dominanten zug
beschreibt aus meiner sicht etwas ist
was man als gefühl bekommen kann wenn
man tatsächlich diese medien zur
kenntnis nimmt und irgendwie ständig
sich von twitter-nachrichten lehmann
west oder gar von irgendwelchen storms
oder sowas und für mich ist die
interessante frage wie maßgeblich ist
das wie maßgeblich ist dieses publikum
was ich in dieser weise äußert und das
jetzt werden diese sendung ausgestrahlt
ist irgendwie ein shitstorm gegenwelt
zur macht mir ist es total wimpel er ist
meist nicht erkennen es kann sein dass
es das gibt mir ist es aber seit es
diese direkt medien gibt immer schon
egal gewesen
es war sagen sie dann umgekehrt der welt
dass diese diskussion vor allen dingen
eben in diesen sozialen medien
stattfinden und gar nicht wirklich auf
der straße auf der straße finden die
doch nicht statt auf der straße findet
doch keine diskussion über die
differenziertheit des gender diskurses
statt
es ist das ist ja nicht der fall das ist
nicht der fall wenn ich mit meiner er
kommt
wir jetzt darüber diskutieren würden die
würden vielleicht sagen ja das ist doch
blödsinn mit den sternchen oder sowas
aber das ist auch schon der diskurs zu
ende und ich finde so tief kann man es
auch legen weil bis ich hab's ja eben
schon gesagt bis zum bestimmten grad
halte ich das für eine modernisierungs
bewegung das ist okay sprache verändert
sich und so weiter ich halte mich selber
für ihn sprach ästheten
deshalb würde ich bestimmte sachen in
meiner eigenen texte so nicht einfließen
lassen die da erforderlich sind so dass
ihre arbeiten sagt er aber es ist eben
keine strache entwicklung sondern wie
gesagt das geht top down
das hat mit entwicklung mit evolution
das ist wird gerne als stichwort gemacht
das hat sprach evolution damit hat das
überhaupt nichts zu tun
es gibt eine elite die einen bestimmten
sprach kodex entwickelt hat und die in
durchsetzt weil sie einen privilegierten
zugang zu den medien und natürlich zu
den bildungsanstalten hat und das
beginnt in der schule und endet noch
lange nicht an den universitäten also
dass da würde ich sagen hat das nichts
mit verschiedener wahrnehmung oder
verschiedenen weltbildern oder so was zu
tun und zu den sozialen medien wie
nennen sie sie direkt medien dieser
sozialen medien sind natürlich ein
rettungsanker für all diejenigen die ihr
weltbild nicht komplett aus den
öffentlich rechtlichen medien beziehen
oder hinter sich haben da kommen wir
gleich nach der ebenfalls ich würde das
nur als balance gerne sehen ich will ich
sein da ist die wahrheit und da ist die
propaganda sondern man braucht diese
balance der verschiedensten medien um
sich überhaupt ein halbwegs
realistisches bild von der welt machen
zu können
ich wollte gerne noch drauf eingehen
meinungsfreiheit ist das eine wir haben
aber in den letzten monaten auch öfter
über cancel culture in ein sieb nun
dieser debatte auch diskutiert das heißt
geht nicht nur um meinungsfreiheit
sondern das geht ja auch um die
kunstfreiheit steht die auch auf dem
spiel
das sehe ich bei uns deshalb nicht oder
nur in bestimmten spektakulären
ausnahmefällen weil die künstlerszene
bei uns zum größten teil so weit ich das
beurteilen kann
selber sympathisiert mit diesen
entwicklungen nicht nennen was man ganz
neutral
also die sind also ich denke die
kunstszene ist doch überwiegend links es
gibt eine sagen eine eine art basis
sozialisation das betrifft nicht nur die
geisteswissenschaften und
kulturwissenschaften sondern im grunde
die meisten bildungsinstitutionen und
ich denke das gilt auch für den größten
teil des kulturbereichs dass man links
sozialisiert wird
ich glaube der unterschied zu früher das
war früher auch schon so er zu meiner
zeit beispielsweise unterschied zu
früher ist nur der dass man heute und
das hängt auch mit den medien zusammen
natürlich sehr viel länger in dieser
blase drin bleiben kann jeder lebt ja
irgendwie in einer informationsblatt
aber früher konnte man die dann auch mal
durchstoßen spätestens dann wenn man
gezwungen war geld zu verdienen und
familie zu gründen oder ähnliches mehr
heute können sie aber in diesen
psychosozialen moratorium bleiben bis
ans ende ihres lebens und das ist
vielleicht das was sie mit
unterschiedlichen weltbildern meinen das
sehe ich in der tat auch als ein großes
problem dass dieses psychosoziale
moratorium diese glocke die sich um
menschen herum bildet die dazu führt
dass man nur noch von ihm meinesgleichen
unseres gleichen informationen aufnimmt
dass die letztlich dazu führt dass man
immun ist gegen realitäts erfahrung und
das verträgt sich außerordentlich gut
mit hoher intelligenz
denn diese leute gegen die ich hier
argumentieren oder die hier kritisiere
bis sind genau wie herr wälzer selbst
hoch intelligent hochgebildet und
rhetorisch brillant und das macht es
natürlich nicht ganz leicht hier so ein
händler das ist nicht sozial ökologische
glocke haben sie gesagt sie öffnete ich
bin zb das mit der intelligenz diesem
befund würde ich gar nicht teilen
das wesentliche merkmal also von dieser
personengruppe von der sie sprechen von
der ich annehme von der sie sprechen
diese elite das was dort doch sozusagen
auf sie als repression hernieder
prasseln ist doch binäres denken da ist
ja keine also für mich ist dieses
sozusagen die fähigkeit zur ambivalenz
die fähigkeit zum zum
in meinen widerspruch zum aushalten von
dingen die nicht zusammenpassen ist für
mich essenziell für das leben das macht
aber die dinge kompliziert aber wenn ich
bin eher denke dann ist das sehr einfach
aber alle binären denkerinnen und denker
die ich kenne sind genau deswegen nicht
ins basilea denken ja also dass deshalb
das argument ja und insofern ist das
etwas was ich vor allen dingen in
unserer zeit breiten dieses binäre
denken ja gut da könnten wir jetzt da
können wir jetzt versuchen das
historisch zu rekonstruieren wann dieser
drang zur vereinfachung einsetzt oder es
ist wer jetzt interessant ihre position
dazu ob das konjunkturen hat ja also
auch zur zeit der studentenbewegung 68
folgende gab es binäres denken und das
ist immer hochattraktiv für leute die
nicht intelligent sind die aber auf sein
ticket fahren und ja dass sie auf sein
ticket fahren und was auch bei dieser
binären denkt denkt und der fall ist das
ist deswegen attraktiv wenn man in der
tat in manchen situationen damit macht
ausüben kann
ja indem man sagt wie bitte so denkst du
noch oder so etwas in der art ja und man
kann sich auch erinnern ich habe das ja
gott sei dank nicht am lebendigen leib
sondern sozusagen direkt miterlebt aber
die ganzen k-gruppen 68 folgende die
sich wechselseitig gesäubert haben weil
sie den richtigen leer so und das ist
dummheit das ist sozusagen ein hohes
niveau von ausgeprägter dummheit und
nicht von intelligenz und das ist das
problem der attraktivität binärer denkt
form das kann man dann nach bethen wenn
man sie einmal gelernt hat und dann kann
man versuchen damit macht aus wenn wir
unterscheiden einmal zwischen sagen wir
ruhig mal dieser politisch medialen
elite auf der einen seite die die so
vielleicht auch in dieser glocke leben
auf der anderen seite ganz normalen
bürgern fall zu so etwas gibt und diese
ganz normalen bürger werden vor allen
dingen auch ein bisschen dadurch
charakterisiert dass sie rhetorisch
nicht ganz so brillant sind und dass sie
wenn sie überhaupt einmal befragt werden
auch die kommen ja manchmal ins
fernsehen oder bekommen ein mikrofon
unter die nase gehalten
dann sind sie meistens vollkommen
unfähig ihre gegenposition zu
artikulieren ich glaube das ist auch ein
ganz ganz großes problem
wenn wir beispielsweise talkrunden haben
im fernsehen oder wo auch immer man
sieht fast immer so aus dass auch einer
dabei ist der aus der realen welt kommt
vielleicht aus der wirtschaft oder oder
vielleicht ein konservativer kommt
manchmal auch vor und diese leute sind
meistens dann rhetorisch den anderen
portal unterlegen und das meinte ich
vorhin mit hochgebildet durchaus auch
intelligent und rhetorisch brillant es
ist dann sehr sehr schwer wenn sie so
wollen so etwas wie gesunden
menschenverstand noch ins spiel zu
bringen
wenn sich mit einer judith butler also
einer dieser kultfigur und dieser szene
konfrontiert sind dann können sie so
vernünftig bürgerlich und rational sein
wie sie wollen
sie haben keine chance gegen dieses
tohuwabohu das da angerichtet wird
und ich glaube das ist ein bisschen das
problem dass wir auch haben uns fehlt im
grunde ein rationaler diskurs und da das
setzt allerdings voraus dass man auch
bereit ist den anderen so etwas wie
humanität menschlichkeit zu zu erkennen
und ihnen in ihnen nicht um menschen zu
sehen und das ist eigentlich das was mir
am meisten angst macht dass viele lehrer
die diese projekte verfolgen und
öffentlich durchsetzen dass die die
andersdenkenden gar nicht mehr als
diskussions gegner betrachten oder als
politische gegner betrachten sondern
dass sie ihn im grunde die moral und die
menschlichkeit absprechen
und das ist wirklich gefährlich und
deshalb sehe ich darin mehr als nur eine
art kultur dies bot das hat oft wirklich
züge auch von einem kulturellen
bürgerkrieg aber wer wählerische leitung
diffamierung dabei wer sind wäre wäre
sie die was ist das für eine machtvolle
gruppe ich verstehe das nicht wer das
ist also das ist es wirklich interessant
wer soll das sein
die politisch mediale elite aber wer ist
denn die politisch mediale elite ja herr
laschet auf jeden fall gehören die
spitzenpolitiker dazu das ist bei uns
nie teil die dieses die sind sozusagen
diejenigen die sie haben vorher 7 dieses
unterscheidet und sie sehen noch große
differenzen zwischen den einzelnen
offiziellen vertretern unserer politik
während leute wie ich eine gewisse
mainstream entwicklung beobachten
innerhalb der politik und leider gottes
auch innerhalb der meisten medien
das heißt also meine meinesgleichen geht
davon aus dass es natürlich nie lassen
die zwischen den verschiedenen parteien
aber das sind new york nehmen wir mal
das große mega beispiel klimawandel
das ist dann die jungs dass die eine
partei sagt wir schalten die
atomkraftwerke in drei jahren ab dann
meldet sich die andere und sagt das ist
ja total reaktionäres muss in einem jahr
sein
da kommt die grüne und sagen nein
nächste woche und freude sofja sagt
morgen das ist der einzige unterschied
genau seit calderón großen gibt gerne
gewissen wissenschaftliche evidenz dafür
dass das problem ist mit dem klimawandel
oder das bezweifelt auch kein
vernünftiger mensch ja aber was soll ich
sagen kann man es diskutieren oder nicht
mehr selbstverständlich kann man das
offensichtlich nicht arbeiten und
schauen sie mal der diskussion mit den
sogenannten klima leutnant also
beispielsweise wo die sich so eine
diskussion mit den klimaanlagen gehen
soll es eine diskussion mit den kurven
eingeben was soll das was wollen sie
denn damit
ja genau das ist die frage sie meinen
also man sollte nicht mit dem was ich
rede auch nicht mit holocaust-leugnern
also entschloss das ist interessant sind
sie das ist eigentlich eine der grund
streich weil wir das was man sagt ja
warum tun sie es dann zu nehmen
holocaust leugner als den inbegriff der
idiotie vielleicht im besten fall
verrückt und übertragen das auf alle
anderen großen unserer zweiten reihe die
nicht im mainstream mitschwimmen sie
sind darüber sie sind doch
wissenschaftler wollen sie denn jede
form von wissenschaftlicher dignität und
evidenz verabschieden das wollen wir uns
vielleicht darf ich aber dazu wollen sie
denn wenn wenn 99,5 prozent aller damit
befassten naturwissenschaftlerinnen
naturwissenschaftler im bereich crm
klimawandel aus den unterschiedlichsten
disziplinen zu denselben ergebnissen
kommen und die sogenannten klima in
europa seit 20 jahren dieselbe nummer
machen dann wollen sie mit denen immer
noch diskutieren und sie halten das
versand des fraktions fähig oder weiß
viel interessanter ist doch dass es ein
außerordentlich schlimmes argument ist
für eine moderne wissenschaftskultur
wenn sie davon aus peters
einheitlichkeit der meinungen wahrheit'
kritisch ist sehr sophistic air als als
modern dann können sie sagen das stimmt
dann aber trotzdem nicht es gibt ja noch
eine andere möglichkeit und wir müssen
uns jetzt mit denen unterhalten die der
auffassung sind auch alle anderen
das hatten sich für eine katastrophe hat
sich viel zeit für schweren browser
würde würde gerne nochmal an dem punkt
anknüpfen wo wir ursprünglich waren
nämlich gerade bei der kunstfreiheit
auch ein stück weit ein professor balls
hat gesagt kunst freiheit die sie der
nicht in irgendeiner form gefährdet weil
die künstler sich dass er
unterschiedliche äußern wenn wir das
stichwort alles dichtmachen einmal sehen
ist das einfach nur schlecht gemachte
satire oder ist das kunst freiheit oder
die auch eingeschränkt fans maximal
dämlich aber das ist doch dann die
angelegenheit von herrn liefers oder
anderen beteiligten damit umzugehen dass
das andere dämlich finden hat die krone
krise dann irgendeiner form zu
verschiebungen geführt
auch was unsere auffassungen angeht von
freiheit also ich finde jetzt nochmal an
dieses wissenschafts thema anzuknüpfen
da war es ja zum beispiel sehr
interessant dass durch die
wissenschaftlichen debatten innerhalb
der ganzen corona zeit eigentlich etwas
aufklärung darüber entstanden ist wie
wissenschaft eigentlich funktioniert
nämlich nicht monolithisch nämlich nicht
als sehr retro sondern dass der
erkenntnis bildungsprozessen einer es
der dann sozusagen kontrovers ist und wo
meinungen sich austauschen
das geht aber nicht bis zum jüngsten tag
es gibt ja bestimmte wissenschaftliche
sachverhalte sind dann mal geklärt und
das hatten wir allerdings virologisch
hier jetzt in der zeit dimension nicht
so schnell hinzukriegen
insofern unterscheidet sich diese
fragestellung von der wissenschaftlichen
meinung über den klima ist ja auch noch
relativ unklar
beim klimawandel gibt es immerhin so
etwas wie lizenzen aber nehmen sie mal
ein problem das scheinbar jetzt
mittlerweile gar nicht mehr als
gewichtig empfinden die meisten leute
nämlich schulden union oder wie immer
man es nennen will
da würde ich doch sagen wäre es nicht so
ganz verkehrt wenn man debattieren würde
aber diese debatte ist sehr schnell
abgewürgt worden in dem es auf der einen
seite waren europäer gab und auf der
anderen seite europagegner wenn sie so
wollen europa leugner holocaust leugnen
und her da kann ich mich schon viele
diskussionen auch hier am tisch
erinnern die durchaus ein breites
meinungsspektrum da hatten aber herr
bolz ich würde gern noch mal fragen
inwiefern wenn sie sagen oder wenn sie
konstatieren dass es durchaus da auch so
eine gewisse spaltung gibt zwischen eine
einer elite und und anderen sage ich
jetzt einfach mal so ist es dann so dass
menschen sich auch ein stück weit
zurückziehen und auch isolieren weil sie
den eindruck haben sie kann nicht mehr
durch absolut nicht bei nicht nur bei
den eindruck haben sie kommen nicht mehr
durch sondern weil sie sich ihre
situation nicht gefährden wollen sie
wollen sich keine unnötigen probleme
machen was ich unglaublich gut verstehen
kann
also ich rate auch meinen kindern habe
ihnen immer geraten seit sich das so
abgezeichnet hat an der universität wenn
es wenn so ein thema aufkommt allmählich
halt lieber euren mund oder überlegt wie
man auch sagen sie gehen denn das in
einer offenen gesellschaft ist der
intime garage aber genauso wie haben sie
ihren kindern beibringen genau die aber
leider ist das soziologischen
irgendeiner form nachweisbar dass sich
menschen auch ein stück weit
zurückziehen wenn sie den eindruck haben
dass sie mit ihrer meinung nicht
durchdringen oder ihre meinung nicht
gehört naja aber wir haben ja jetzt
innerhalb der wieso man sagen dieses
rechten spektrums den großen mythos dass
meinungsfreiheit so etwas ist wo man
dann gewissermaßen nicht mehr eine
meinung die geäußert wird kritisieren
darf also das prinzip von rhede und
gegen geräte gilt ja in diesem phantasma
nicht und da fangen die probleme an
meinungsfreiheit bedeutet ja schon dass
man das was ich jetzt hier sage von
herrn balls oder vielen anderen
zuschauerin und so weiter durchaus
kritisieren lassen kann und das halte
ich auch aus finde ich auch irgendwie
super ich finds er auch traurig wenn das
nicht der fall wäre
aber dieses
ist ja nach wie vor in unserem land
gegeben ich würde das niemals so
stilisieren dass er so und wenn ich dann
wie sie es jetzt eben in bezug auf ihre
kinder beschrieben haben
wenn das der fall wäre würde ich es doch
der würde ich doch als vater sagen lasst
euch doch nicht ins bockshorn jagen von
irgendwelchen theorie heinis oder oder
frauen die da irgendwie versuchen einen
bestimmten stil durch das design ist
dass man einfach auch professoren
theorie schließen die die feinde der
demokratie glauben sie dass da eine
gefahr besteht dass mit den schlagworten
meinungs- dogmatismus geworben wird und
die dann auch mehr zulauf bekommen ja
das weiß ich nicht ob die mehr zulauf
bekommen aber sozusagen etwas was sehr
einfach funktioniert hat immer eine
attraktion wert für bestimmte menschen
und zwar sozusagen schicht und bildungs
unspezifisch also wo es einfach wird ist
es attraktiv und ich würde ihnen auch
den punkt geben
auch das gilt innerhalb von
universitäten
es gibt auch bestimmte wissenschaftliche
lehrmeinung die sind wegen ihrer
einfachheit attraktiver für bestimmte
wünschen also etwas kompliziertere das
ist einfach so und populismus operiert
ja genau auf dieser ebene nämlich
mitzuteilen wo demarkationslinien
zwischen richtig und falsch genau sind
und das hat den effekt dass man sich
dann zuordnen kann und das ist gut für
das ego und das ist auch gut um das
gefühl zu haben ich gehöre zu einer
gemeinde einer gruppe so und deshalb
funktioniert das ganze und wenn man
dagegen sagt man ja die welt ist
kompliziert und so ist die gemeinde
bildung etwas schwieriger ist denn diese
umfrage die wir am anfang nie akzeptiert
haben auch schon ein stück weit ausdruck
des populismus
ich würde so weit nicht gehen ich finde
es ist eine eine besorgnis erregendes
ergebnis erst mal so ohne dass ich jetzt
wie gesagt ich würde der sache nachgehen
ich denke das ist notwendig
weitere studien in dieser richtung zu
machen wenn dieses gefühl möglich so
verbreitet ist wie es in dieser aufnahme
gewissermaßen dokumentiert ist dann
haben wir ein problem mit der demokratie
und ich möchte ja noch mal einen satz
sagen es fehlt ja sozusagen auch der
referenzpunkt dafür also wenn wir über
belarus sprechen
selbst wenn wir über ungarn sprechen und
so weiter haben wir ja eine ganz andere
repressions situation für menschen die
ihre meinung sagen als dass hier in
diesem land der fall ist deshalb finde
ich auch dieses beispiel mit ihren
kindern verstörend ich finde dass
verstörend warum ermutigen die sie die
nicht zum zum selbst denken und zum zum
so zivi oder als ich verstehen dafür aus
dass selbst denkt nur überhaupt
praktizieren könnten nämlich dass sie
erstens bei ihrer ausbildung so gut wie
möglich zu ende führen können ohne dass
sie unter ausschluss mechanismen leiden
müssen oder ohne mit repressalien
rechnen zu müssen und dann sich mit
denjenigen leuten auszutauschen die so
etwas wie freie meinungsäußerung
überhaupt zulassen denn in einem punkt
glaube ich liegen sie wirklich falsch
wenn was modernität des argumentieren
und damit auch der wissenschaft betrifft
und das ist der hauptpunkt den john
stuart mill gemacht hat in dem buch das
von liberty heißt über freiheit und der
hauptpunkt von milch war nämlich zu
sagen wenn es unter millionen auch nur
einen einzigen menschen gibt der eine
abweichende meinung hat dann sollte man
die hören und mit über sie diskutieren
denn das ist eine fantastische
möglichkeit für die mehrheit durch gute
argumente gegen diese abweichende
meinung zu zeigen dass sie auf dem
richtigen weg ist
laut dass diese droht gesagt dass der
gedanke der liberalität der freiheit und
den sollten wir bieten sich diesen
gesagt hätte das nicht 30 jahre lang mit
derselben abweichenden meinung
durchgehalten und in the air und
inwiefern herr welser ist es denn so
wenn der einzelne eine eigene meinung
hat
inwiefern besteht denn da die gefahr
dass er das im eigenen interesse auch
überhöht
sind das die repression überhöht das
welcher gefahr er sich dabei aus setzt
nicht die repression sondern sein
eigeninteresse wenn der einzelne eine
andere meinung hat inwiefern hat der
denn nur großes interesse daran dass
diese meinung sozusagen die hat es das
dass er das zu einem falsch verstandenen
föderalismus erhöht ja das kann durchaus
passieren
natürlich haben menschen besonders
solche mit starken meinungen häufig
einen missionarischen trank und wundern
sich stefan brangs bis abends dass die
anderen dieser meinung noch gar nicht
übernommen haben das lässt sich schon
gewählt durch beobachten ja das heißt es
gibt auch kein stück mehr eine konsens
pflicht einen aufeinander eingehen in
unserer gesellschaft
naja ich glaube es gibt es gibt er ein
defizit auf der ebene dessen was man
vielleicht als streitkultur bezeichnen
könnte
und was ich attraktiv finden könnte es
gibt nämlich noch eine andere anderes
phänomen in diesem ganzen spektrum und
das ist eigentlich wenn man wenn man
etwas versucht auf der ebene der sache
über die man diskutiert zu diskutieren
oder zu kritisieren
dann wird das sofort persönlich genommen
als angriff gegen die eigene person
und dann wird entsprechend auch
beleidigend oder sonstwas beleidigt
beleidigend zurück geschossen da gibt es
eine kulturelle veränderung das ist
relativ
schwierig finde ich es gehört aber zu
diesen formen kreisen die differenzen
nicht aushalten
genau das heißt wir müssen an unsere
streiks zu arbeiten deshalb würde ich
gerne ihren begriff sie sagt einen
konsens pflicht global aufgehalten würde
sagen gerade das nicht wir bräuchten die
kraft zum dissens
also wie sie eben gesagt haben es
aushalten können und das betrifft ja
auch wenn sie so wollen diese emotionale
betroffenheit von dem worum es geht oder
was gerade argumentiert wird das ist das
allererste was man lernen müsste und im
grunde geht es um das was max weber mal
politikern zu schreiben wollte den guten
politiker nämlich leidenschaft und
sachlichkeit
also man sollte schon leidenschaftlich
sein und leidenschaftlich diskutieren
aber dabei sachlich bleiben und
sachlichkeit zeigt sich eben gerade auch
darin dass man anderen zuhört und dass
man interesse an der meinung anderer
oder an den argumenten von anderen hat
und das ist eigentlich das was
universitäten ursprünglich mal aus
bilden wollten die wollten leute
ausbilden die interesse an
gegenargumenten haben oder wie puppe die
absolute ikone der modernen
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse niemals
so schön gesagt hat connectors machen
wir aber auch reputations also
widerlegung ja also ist der
wissenschaftler hat geradezu lust daran
widerlegt zu werden und nicht im konsens
der massen aufzugehen
und genau dieser geist der fehlt uns wie
groß ist ihre sorge herr professor
welter dass wir unsere streitkultur gar
nicht mehr richtig pflegen und gar nicht
mehr richtig streiten können na ja also
dass ich war also ich habe deswegen
keine schlaflosen nächte sagen wir es
mal so ich sehe dass es da bestimmt die
soll man sagen extreme gibt also die ich
eben als binär bezeichne ich sehe auch
das ist dann mein stichwort waren von
bestimmte hochschulleitungen die dann
dem
sozusagen nicht die entsprechende
widerstand entgegen bringen so etwas
aber ich würde auch immer noch sagen man
muss dann genau hingucken welche teile
oder welche begründungen einer solchen
die beim gender einer solchen ja solche
wünsche gesellschaft zu modernisieren
welche dann vielleicht auch folgerichtig
und also ich streite mich nämlich zum
beispiel mit meinem sohn genau über
solche fragen der mir dann doch
eindringlich irgendwie bei bestimmten
stellen mitteilt das wäre jetzt eben
auch ein anderer diskursen und dann muss
ich natürlich in meinem alter das auch
mal zur kenntnis nehmen dass es
vielleicht auch eine berechtigung hat
einen solchen diskurs zu führen wenn man
anfang zwanzig oder so ist ich meine die
die zeiten verändern sich ja nun auch
mal und jedes nicht jedes anliegen ist
nicht legitim nur weil wir es nicht
verstehen weil das evolution ist aber
leider ja ich muss aber leider sagen
dass wir am ende der zeit sind ich
bedanke mich sehr herzlich für diese
sehr engagierte diskussion ich glaube
wir haben hier zwei am tisch die sich
nicht gescheut haben ihre meinung zu
sagen und ich bedanke mich bei ihnen
sehr hat sich fürs zuschauen
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen abend
[Musik]